[Music]
pain
lately i've become very well acquainted
with it
the type that comes when you've been
hurt repeatedly by the same person
you've been gushing about seattle since
the day i first met you
if he loves you he could follow you
i was hoping that we would move to
london after graduation
and how was i supposed to know that
only in those rare moments when he pulls
me to his chest
and makes promises he never seems able
to keep
does the pain disappear
relationships they're complicated
you have a great job in seattle but i
don't have anything there
you'd have me okay that's not enough if
i'm not enough
that's your problem but you're not going
to stop me
i won't give up seattle for you so you
just turn on me
this is what you do you sabotage every
good moment that we have no no if i
wanted to try and sabotage a good moment
i would have brought
another guy's number in your dress you
don't get to choose who i have his
friends they don't want to be your
friends okay
i can't tell it's true and what's not
enough
[Music]
you're my better place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you